cuáles son las implicaciones de las
sanciones aprobadas hoy tanto para rusia
como para los demás países europeos
a contra vale tiene muchas gracias por
esta argentina invitación y respondiendo
para ti nada pregunta me parece que por
dos días hay que verlo
la primera óptica es cómo le va a
afectar este no ingresó a rusia de los
20 mil millones de euros que recibía
justo por sus exportaciones del petróleo
pero por la otra óptica es como es que
ahora la unión europea tendrá que
reconfigurar el suministro energético a
la luz de este sexto paquete de
sanciones donde dejarán de importar el
90 por ciento petróleo proviniendo de
rusia sin embargo pues que sabemos que
lo que es hungría república checa y
eslovaquia pues tal todavía hay en un
momento de sesión y de pausa justamente
los países acuerdan un embargo parcial
de las importaciones de petróleo ruso a
qué situaciones particulares se debe que
esta medida sea parcial y no total
claro valentín ha derivado a que estos
tres países no tienen acceso vía
marítima para poder tener su comercio
exterior pues ellos requieren
forzosamente que sea a través de un
oleoducto para poder importar el
petróleo y por la geografía y por el
producto que comunica a rusia con estas
tres naciones pues únicamente puede ser
a través de este canal conocido como hoy
te has movido el nombre pero es un
oleoducto que llega directamente de
rusia a estos tres países y por lo tanto
ellos no están en condiciones de entrar
en el paquete como el resto de los
países de la unión europea para buscar
otros proveedores sustitutos esta gran
dependencia no nada más de rusia hacia
las naciones sino también del unión
europea con respecto a rusia está siendo
muy complicado el poder avanzar esta
nueva arquitectura de paquetes de
sanciones para poder en algún momento se
está con julián compensa deseando más de
seis meses ya sea un total de cortes de
suministro hacia el petróleo ruso cuál
podría ser la respuesta de moscú que ya
hoy cortó el suministro de gas a países
bajos y mañana se lo corta de dinamarca
así es valentina el hecho de esta
exigencia de que el pago sea a través de
rubros es porque vladimir putin lo que
busca es una nueva arquitectura
financiera internacional pero también
dejar a un lado la hegemonía del dólar
sin embargo pues ante este sexto paquete
de sanciones seguramente estaremos
viendo que creen y no se dejará esperar
seguirá cerrando las válvulas pero
también seguirá atacando y seguirá
implementando una ofensiva militar
seguramente mucho más agresiva en
territorio ucraniano valentín